- Whoa, dude.
Five's my favorite number.
Five's not your
favorite number, is it?
- No.
- [Other Tyler] It's four.
- Ah!
You've watch everything.
Give me something.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
Just gave a talk to
a school this morning,
eighth graders.
Lot of fun.
Now on the way to record and
film the Breakfast Club which
was a real
amazing moment of 2016.
Brought some awareness to
my work to a lot of different
people which I enjoyed.
Become very fond of all the
characters over there and so
gonna come back and
answer some more questions.
Looking forward to that.
And a day of a lot
of different meetings.
Should be an interesting day.
Feeling good.
It's been, you know, I actually
love to get six hours of sleep.
Sometimes even sneak in a seven.
Obviously, I have a
lot of fours and fives.
This has been a
consistent four and five week,
so last two days feel
a little like run down
in the morning but,
you know, very
quickly it changes.
The energy can go
from 0 to 100 real quick.
Hey, hey, hey, good morning.
DRock in the house.
Things are good.
Hope everybody's super well.
Thank you so much, Nedal.
How's everybody doing with
their eBay challenge
$20,000, $20,170?
Yeah, baby shit,
sell that baby shit.
Baby shit sells.
Good stuff.
It does.
That's one of
my favorite things.
People own all
these baby clothes and
all these baby items.
They got no babies no more.
Some of you have babies.
Just sitting in the attic.
And they do a garage sale,
sell it for a dollar
for 90 things
that could have sold for $1100.
Ooh, GaryVeeShop.com.
These t-shirts, it's ready.
T-shirts are, you think
you're gonna be
pumped with the t-shirts?
- [DRock] Yeah.
Pretty cool.
- You gonna buy a t-shirt.
- [DRock] Sure,
I'll buy a t-shirt.
- How about four?
- [DRock] Eh, think so.
- I think you should buy four.
- [DRock] I'll buy four
and then give three away.
- Ooh, what?!?
- [DRock] Yep.
I'll buy four and
then give three away.
- DRock, I'm very proud of you.
I think you should
buy six. (Avi laughs)
Avi, I'm a salesman,
man, don't laugh.
You like this, right?
This is a clinic.
This is how you do it.
Keep going 'til they say no.
Keep going until they say no.
Don't say no for the other guy.
Not you.
You want to be good at sales?
Keep selling until they say no.
Would you like
some, I'd like some wine.
Would you like a case?
Yeah. Great, okay.
Maybe another case.
Okay.
Maybe you should buy a case and
it away for your kid one day.
Okay. Maybe, stop.
Okay, good, three cases.
Better than one.
(Avi laughs)
Let's see.
Always communicate.
It's the culture.
It's the people.
It's never, ever, ever, ever,
ever anything other than that.
It's about people.
When you go from
one to five locations,
it's about people.
That's the fucking game.
Don't get it confused.
That's 100% the game.
Mark, good to see you.
What's up, Shannon?
Good to see you.
$20,000 in profit, Southern.
You don't pay
bills with the sales,
you pay with the profit.
Profit, profit,
profit, profit, profit.
Profit.
I'll keep the content comin'.
Love you guys,
love you Sam Benrubi.
Please, please,
please, oh Richie.
Richie South.
Please, please,
please keep it comin',
keep building your shit.
Sell shit, do shit.
Do it, do it, do it and
I wish you guys huge love.
Alright, I got to go
in film Breakfast Club.
Looking forward to it.
DRock is filming
so we'll catch it.
I'll see you guys later.
Russian hustle for life.
- [Man] That's how you do.
- [Gary] That's how I do, too.
(group laughter)
How are you?
- How you doin', man?
You is the man, man.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
How are you?
I run a business.
- You do?
What is it?
- [Gary] An agency,
a social media agency.
- Wow.
- [Gary] So we
help Under Armour,
Toyota, do all the
Facebook, Instagram,
Snapchat shit.
- You like that, man?
I do a bunch of things, man.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you, man.
Good luck to you.
Keep hustling.
- Yes man, always man.
- [Gary] Stay well.
Moral of that story is, you
could be picking up 5,000 people
a day on Instagram but if you
don't take the time and say
hello and put
just one person on,
that's only gonna
last for so long.
- [Man 2] G, what's up?
- [Gary] What up, my man?
'Sup man?
How you doing?
How you doing, my man?
Good to see you.
- Good to see you too.
- [Gary] Oh Mehmit.
Mehmit's my man.
'Sup man?
What's up everybody?
It's GaryVee.
Wake up every morning with
Breakfast Club only on Revolt.
- [Man 3] Perfect.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- [Gary] You got it.
- [Man 3] Thank you.
- [Gary] 'Sup man?
- [Dan] Dan.
- [Gary] Dan.
- [Dan] It's a pleasure.
- [Gary] Real pleasure, man.
- [Man 4] Wake that ass up.
- That's it?
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- Wake that ass up.
(group laughter)
That was the best part.
Cool, man.
- [Man 4] Awesome.
Thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- [Woman] Gary, we're gonna
have you do one more drop.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Mehmet] How's
life treating ya?
- [Gary] Really good.
- [Mehmet] Doing well?
AJ's well?
- [Gary] AJ's doing really well.
Thank you.
- What's up my brother?
- [Gary] 'Sup my man?
Great to see you.
- How things been?
- [Gary] I saw you at CES.
You were sitting with some
guys, I was with Dan Gilbert.
Sitting right behind you.
I was calling your name.
Then I got pulled, then
I looked and I didn't see you
and I had to go.
And I was like,
"Fuck, I let Mehmet go."
- It's alright,
it's good to see you.
It was a great meeting.
Man, that's gotten big.
- Yeah.
- I went there with Tom
Hanks and Howard Stringer
when he was head of Tony.
- Yes.
- And this is
probably 10 years ago.
It was before the show launched.
- It was when it was
really an electronics show.
Now it's just a business.
Good for you, man.
- [Mehmet] Alright, buddy.
- Continued success.
- [Man 3] Dr. Oz, can
I grab you for a second?
We're just going
to do a quick promo,
tune in video.
- [Gary] Yeah.
I'm up?
- [Envy] You up!
- [Gary] Envy, what's up?
Love the kicks, man.
- Good to see you.
- [Gary] Life is good?
How's your little man?
- Good.
- [Gary] Life's good.
- Got five, they all good.
- [Envy] How far are
you from buying the Jets?
- I think I'm very
far and very close.
So let me explain.
- [Envy] Okay.
- I love patience.
I got a lot of things
in place on third base that
I haven't cashed in on.
There's a lot of things I can
do if tomorrow it has to happen.
Call in (mimics phone ringing),
call in all those favors,
cash in all those chips.
Sell all the, you know,
my company just did a huge
transaction that valued
the company at a $400 million
valuation that puts my
net worth at $200 million of
what I own of that.
I've got all this paper money on
Facebook I can cash it all in.
It's on the stock market.
I've got private money in
Uber and other things that I can
convert to somebody else.
I've got pieces but
Woody's not selling
and the truth is I don't
have the $2.7 billion.
I'm nowhere close to that.
Now, and I don't want to go
round up a lot of
people to be a partner.
I want to run shit.
I need to win a Super Bowl.
So the good news
is he's still young.
You know, I wish him
health every single day.
I would love to have another
15 to 20 years to make the play.
But the truth is Envy, the
journey to try to buy them,
that's the game.
- [Envy] That's the game.
- Last night
Richie South and Boyd,
we go to the studio, right?
You know what I love?
You know why
I love hip hop the most?
'Cause people that are
really in it, they work.
Like I'm in Corporate America.
I'm in Silicon Valley.
Actually that's why I fell
in love with Silicon Valley.
Those nerds, they worked
like my hip hop friends did.
- [Envy] Mhmmm.
- I'm like, "Wait a minute,
"these kids are coding
at 2 in the morning?" Right?
Like going in the
studio last night at midtown
at 12 and watching everybody work.
Dave needs to work.
He's working.
They're working.
- [Woman 2] Oh, you were there
with Yung Berg and everybody?
- I was with Berg last night.
- [Cha] He was--
- Oh, he was on the
show with you, right?
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- Yeah.
And you know why?
- [Woman 2] That's funny.
- It motivates me.
Because in Corporate America
when I go sit with CMOs and CEOs
of Fortune 500 companies,
they don't work like this.
They're done at 6.
- [Cha] Our guy GaryVee,
always a pleasure, man.
- [Gary] Love you, man.
- [Cha] Yes sir,
love you too, brother.
- [Man 5] Yes sir, that's great.
- [Gary] Real
pleasure. Pleasure.
- [Man 5] Thank you very much.
- My man. Thank you my man.
- [Cha] DRock!
- [Envy] About to
hit the click right now.
(Gary laughs)
- [Angela] One of them I'm about
to sell but the other two I'm
keeping because you know--
- I'm really
looking at all of them.
We're talking about thousands of
people who's life is better now.
- Absolutely.
- Like crazy shit.
- That's a good way
to set up the voicemail.
We can have people
call and leave questions.
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's a
cool. I love that.
- And then you go
through 'em quick.
- Yeah.
- We can just do #AskGaryVee.
That's easy.
- Alright, my man.
Stay well.
I'll talk to you.
- [Angela] Alright.
- [Gary] Bye darlin'.
- [Mike] That's so dope.
- [Envy] Alright,
brother. Thank you.
- [Gary] Talk to you soon, man.
- [Woman 3] Bye, y'all.
- [Gary] Bye guys.
- [DRock] Later.
("Manifest" by Russ)
- I'm happy and I feel
guilty about what happened.
Almost so much so I just want
to give it to everybody else.
And let that be a lesson for
the next 50 years
that we jam together.
That if you ever want context,
it doesn't seem like it was
bothering you,--
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- but anytime like
this is my new thing.
This is the first time
you're gonna hear me say it.
I'm going with a new tactic
in these first time meetings,
anytime something happens that
you don't understand or like and
you want to know,--
- [Man 6] Mhmmm.
- I'm super cozy to tell you.
I've got this big dream of a
town hall meeting but I realize
that's only going
to bring me so much.
So now my new move is to let
them know from the first moment
they sit with me, call my bluff.
- [Man 6] Yeah, uh-huh.
- And again, whatever you deem
as important and not important.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- I'm sure
that's not the craziest,
I'm sure that's not the craziest
thing that's ever happened.
But everybody's different.
It's insane what
people think is--
- [Man 6] I think...
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
Hit me up if I can be a help.
- Awesome.
- [Gary] Stay well, man.
- DRock.
- [DRock] Later, man.
- 'Sup man?
- [Gary] Hey dude.
- Like your new house.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
Just going on Instagram Live for
a second but I'll shut it down.
How are you?
- Or I can jump in.
- Okay, well I mean, listen,
they're gonna shit
their pants if you jump in.
- So let me get
this straight, you're,
are we on live right now?
- We're live.
- Hi.
I'm giving myself a
tour of Gary's new office.
Let me get this straight,
there's not a building there.
- Nuh-uh.
- Yeah, you might want to get
somebody to clean the windows.
If you've got a rope
I'll go out there myself.
We'll do it right now.
- [Gary] Well, that's
how you make your content.
Why don't you just drone
up here and just clean it?
There it is the next
piece of content figured out.
First and foremost,
congrats, brother.
- Yeah.
- So happy for you.
- Thank you.
- Such a good deal.
I've never said this,
the day after I stopped doing
Wine Library TV, I did
it five and a half years.
I did five days a week.
In five years, I did
a 1,089 episodes and
I didn't do weekends.
So when you start
compounding that math,
it was like the world
came off my shoulders.
And it was my favorite
thing, but when it was over
and I knew it was over,
I did something weird.
I actually did something
a lot of people don't know.
I did Wine Library TV
to Episode 1000,
and then I started
something called Daily Grape,
which was a
shorter mobile version.
Because I knew I
was done at a 1000,
but I wasn't ready to let go,
it was this weird thing.
So I'm like if I'm gonna do it,
let me learn something
new and I think these mobile
devices are gonna take over.
So I did that but
I only did it for 89 episodes.
It never had a
chance and I ended it.
- [Casey] Too early.
- Yeah.
- [Casey] Ahead of your time.
- No. It was killing.
And I was making money
because I actually for
the first time actually was
selling wine
reviews like Wine Spectator.
It would've
been a huge business.
I was just done doing
daily content that way.
- You know what's an
interesting vertical for me?
Don't put this in the video.
- It's not a by accident thing
that things happen to us.
It's this zone.
- [Casey] Absolutely. It's just
that traditional media has
existed for so long and
it's so slow to change and
it's so big.
- [Gary] It's not their fault.
- It's not their fault.
- [Gary] It's too big.
- They can't pivot,
they can't move--
- [Gary] Which is
why this move by them
getting you
involved is so right.
Instagram is so important.
- See their daily
numbers for stories?
150 million.
Daily active users and stories.
- So.
- That product is what,
a few months old?
- Yeah, I mean
they have the attention.
They funneled people that way.
What you do, again,
the people that win.
You do not
disrespect that attention.
You'll do nothing than
So once you figure out--
- I hope not.
- Once you figure out exactly,
you'll deploy it against
that attention, with
value to that attention, and it
will be a hit from the gate.
That's exactly what's
gonna happen, and that's why
they stole it in a
world where everybody's like,
people don't understand magic.
People don't understand.
(hip hop music)
- Like your view of
Empire State Building out of the
window, this is the view of the
Empire State
Building from my bed.
- [DRock] Oh no.
- Yeah.
- There's the Empire
State Building, this is my bed.
- Yeah.
- It's because I need
to eat, breathe and sleep
New York City when I wake up.
You can't show
it on camera, right?
Solid meeting, thanks
for having me by Gary.
(Gary laughs)
- [Casey] Oh you
gotta come down.
- Anytime.
- [Casey] You gotta
come down too, see the shop.
- I fuckin' love it man.
- [Casey] Just make sure you
watch the video I posted today,
it's about exactly
what you just said.
- Cool.
- It's about this idea of--
- [DRock] Are
you gonna watch it?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- [Casey] I would
never hold you to it,
I would never hold you to it.
- I'm gonna watch my
first Casey video. (laughs)
- I would never hold you to
it, it's like eight minutes.
- DRock, DRock, have you
ever watched a Casey video?
- [DRock] No.
(group laughter)
- But the one today is
about this sort of thing that
Felix, PewDiePie, talked about
last week which is like--
- Woah, dude,
five's my favorite number.
Five's not your
favorite number is it?
- [Other Tyler] It's
four I'm sorry.
- You've watched everything,
give me something.
- We'll talk soon,
come by anytime, I'll
see you on the internet.
- [Man 7] I don't if this
happened to you guys, but one
of the kind of
objections that we get all the
time is, you know, we
have people who do this or our
kids do this or you know,
we've got people internally who
do this and you know.
- I tell them there's a big
difference between the way
I play basketball and the way
LeBron James plays basketball.
There's no accident that
L is the best you've got.
You just tell them right
to their fuckin' face that
we're better at it.
- [Man 7] Yeah.
- And if they say, "Well we
don't value the difference
between our B player and your A
player" then you say Mazel Tov
and you go over
to the next building.
- [Man 7] Yeah.
Don't dwell on
that conversation.
Tell them right to their face
what you believe and move on.
- [Man 7] Cool.
- I mean it's that basic,
what are you gonna try to
convince the unsellable?
- [Man 7] Right.
- I don't give a
fuck what your excuse is,
it's the excuse and I'm leaving.
You need to really
nail that one in your brain,
it will be the best thing
that happens to your business.
- [Man 7 ] Awesome.
- Sitting in your bed crying
about the girl that didn't
want to go out with
you for a year is not gonna
let you find the next girl.
- [Man 7] Yeah, agreed.
- Next.
- [Man 7] Agreed.
When you're an entrepreneur
you have an wavering eye.
- [Man 7] Yeah, totally.
- You're unfaithful, that
skirt looks cute, I get it.
I've never, you know, when
it comes to entrepreneurship
I'm playing the field
hard, I'm super in love
with Vayner but
I'm like, who's that?
And that happens to me
every day, I'm a scum bucket
when it comes to
entrepreneurship.
And I would tell you that
you can go and have a little
more fun once you've
got a little bit of an
established situation.
So I would say that,
be very careful of not
doing it too early and
realize, you know there
was something
I said the other day like,
"Eat shit for 24
months and then eat
"caviar for the
rest of your life."
It's not that exact but that's
how I think about it here,
build something
that gives you the,
you know, build
something and then when
it's got enough
strength go do it.
The reason there was a big
gap in me putting out content
was I needed 2011, '12 and
'13 to build Vayner, it allowed
me then to get
back into content,
do the PureWow deal, you know.
- [Man 7] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That was very kind.
- [Man 7] I really appreciate it.
- [Gary] So happy it
worked out for you, man.
That gratitude, brother,
drive with that, do not let
any, like, when I gave
you that first answer to that
question now, that should've
been a forgone conclusion for
you.
- [Man 7] Yeah.
- Comparatively, do never,
you know, this is what happens
with life threatening
events, you forget.
It's like when the cop
car goes and then when it
drives back by you,
you get and then
you start driving fast again.
People don't realize this,
you do, I understand and
thank god I've never had it,
people forget, do not forget.
- [Man 7] It's just a
video game for me now.
- But you know what,
don't say it, live it.
- [Man 7] Right.
- Losing that client, somebody
saying no, it means nothing.
- [Man 7] Right.
- Bye guys.
- [Gary] Bye bye.
- I just wanted to make sure.
- Let me sleep on it,
get me some context.
- [Andy] I mean we're spending
money but it's like, you still
have to maintain the
accounts, so on and so for.
- Hi.
- I'm Kelly.
- Kelly.
- Nice to meet you.
- How're you.
- Hi, Dana.
- Dana, how're you?
- Good to meet you.
- This is so weird.
(group laughter)
With building my
dad's liquor store,
it should've been a $200
million business, I wasn't
smart enough to go
all in on Google AdWords,
I kind of went
all in on AdWords.
It's insane to me, like I
don't even want to actually
put my brain on the
table for you guys to see on
how I think about
PureWow and Instagram.
Because it would
make you nervous,
because you would
then be concerned
that I'm so disrespectful
to everything else.
So, with that opening statement,
that's how I feel about
things, that's
why I think I win.
So to me, that
could go away tomorrow.
The reason I've been
successful with clients,
with my investments,
with things that are not 100%
my call, we're
super successful because
we look at each
other and we just do it.
Everything else is
hard, Vayner's hard.
This is easy, we
just do it, I just do it
and when they have
an idea I'm like do it.
Just do it, and we do
it and it's just doing it.
Vayner's hard, we have to do.
So, I do it, but I have to do
a couple of things beforehand
and this will be one
even step more than that,
and that's okay, but
this is what I'm about.
You know, and it's
gonna work, in a real way.
- Cool.
- Love you guys.
- Thank you.
- See ya.
See where the opportunities are.
- [Man 9] Exactly.
- It's the right move.
- Help first and then--
- Cool, I'm excited.
- [Man 9] Don't, even.
- How are you doing?
I see you like every
day on TV or on YouTube,
so I'm like "Hi, Gary."
- I have a crazy
proposition for you.
- [Amber] Okay.
- I (censored).
- This office is amazing.
This is so, this is just.
- I forgot.
It just like makes my
heart swell to see this.
It's so great.
Here's my feelings as a father
and as a man in the world
and someone who's tried
to focus a lot of my life
on impacting as
many people as I could,
as far and wide as
I could in a positive way.
Suddenly I,--
- It got real small.
- all I cared about was just
being in the room with them.
- [Gary] Yeah it got real small.
- Do you try and
live as big as possible
or as small as possible and
where do you find a balance?
- [Gary] And you know
what the best part is?
The answer is always both.
Clouds and dirt,
baby, clouds and dirt.
- [Adam] It was like
well, for a moment I felt like,
I just, I don't
care about anything.
I just want to be
in this room with them.
Then I realized,
well, they're going
to grow up into the world.
- Well, you know.
- [Adam] And I
would set the example.
- Parents and marketers
and business people,
they cripple themselves,
they cripple themselves
in not realizing you
can be 100% on something,
even for a year.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Everybody thinks in the micro.
- Like if I want to be
super selfish for two years,
it's two of the 100
years I'm going to live.
- [Adam] Right. Right.
- Like, people
don't quantify that.
I'll go in the dirt
for, the VaynerMedia.
I was in the clouds
for the last six months,
I'm getting in
the dirt, you know.
People judge
themselves too much.
It's okay to go on a
business trip for three weeks.
It's three weeks.
- [Adam] Yeah, yeah,
that's been the new thing.
- It's okay that
especially, I mean look
this is so much of
the advice I gave you
on the board, right?
- Well, let me give
you the MissionU update.
- [Gary] Yeah, I want that.
- And I want a lot
of your thoughts and.
- [Gary] Let's
do it, let's do it.
- So.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] I don't
even read a business plan
if somebody puts
it in front of me.
Somebody else would never even
consider giving you money.
- Without that.
- [Gary] Correct.
- Right.
- [Gary] Reverse
engineer the person.
- Cool, customize
it to that, yeah.
- I mean that, this is why
you get conflicting opinions.
It's why everybody
gets conflicting opinions.
Because there's more
than one way to do it.
- [Man 10] Yeah.
But you need to know
who you're doing it with.
You come in here and
give me a business plan
and you actually knew a little
bit about my spiel, I'm out.
Like if you didn't know me--
- [Man 10] Is that
just like your personal
sort of approach to.
- Yes because
it's just how I bet.
- [Man 10] Got it, yeah.
- But like you go to
a Goldman Sachs kid
who, like, has
public information
that she only believes in data,
and you walk in
there and try to do
the GaryVee thing,
you're fucked.
- [Man 10] Yeah,
I think just personally
that's what I've just
been hitting myself with like,
what do I really believe in most
in terms of how
I want to sell my--
- Well the answer
is both, always.
It depends on is it
50/50, 80/20, 100/0, right?
- Yeah, you've got to balance
on your, yeah, okay, yeah.
- The other thing is just do it.
Like, it's a hell of a
lot better for you to go
0 for 7 pitching your business
than sitting in
your head on your couch.
- [Man 10] Yep.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] I'm hopeful, it
feels a lot better today.
I go from buying
cheeseburgers, I'm about
to buy you a nice
dinner, like, it's good,
and then it goes down.
The economy gets
fucking terrible,
I got to start over,
there's like so much shit.
You just gotta
keep fighting, man.
Especially if you love it.
That's the other thing
about music and technology,
if you love it, then
that's a whole different thing.
I can eat cheeseburger,
I'll be straight up.
I can eat
cheeseburgers every day.
I don't need anything fancy.
I need to play my game.
That's what drives me.
That's why I'm the best.
'Cause I'm going to win
'cause I play it for the game.
I don't need shit,
I don't need shit.
And I don't hate on
people that want stuff.
Everybody knows what they want.
I want the game.
I don't even want the money.
I really don't, you know this.
- [Mike] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know this
better than anybody.
You know, you know
my, you know, you do.
You know how I play.
I want the the fucking action.
- That's exactly what I said.
So once I pay you, you
connect 'em with, I'm tellin'.
- You know this is exact advice
I gave to Saba yesterday.
Get into culture outside
of your own fucking world.
- [Man 12] Yeah, but
that's not my world.
- No.
- [Man 12] These are
gamers, just sayin'.
- Like you guys should go
get a fucking country singer
to sing a hook on
some of your shit.
Get some pretty
blond girl that has 800,000
Instagram followers
and does country.
I don't know what kind of
musician you, I don't want.
The one thing I always
don't is touch the art.
That's what people do, that's...
But I'm always giving
them, if you're into it,
or you're that kind of artist,
you do it, your shit will pop.
- [Man 12] See that's what--
- Yeah man, I remember
the first time I got
offered to speak for real.
This is a good story.
Dude calls, he goes, we
want you to give the keynote
at the Internet
Marketing Conference.
How much do you charge?
I was about to say, cool.
I was about to say but,
he was talking slow,
he didn't get to say,
how much do you charge?
I was almost going to
be like, sure I'll come,
just pay my trip, right?
He was like, how
much do you charge?
I'm like, uh, okay.
I was like, all right, what.
So I'm a businessman.
So I'm like, okay,
I have no idea
what people get paid to speak,
but I'm going to throw out the
craziest fucking number ever,
because I can always come down.
So I'm like,
$5,000.
He goes, okay great,
we'll send you the paperwork.
I be like, holy shit!
He said yes fast as fuck.
So I was like, he was
talking, I'm blacked out.
I'm happy, and I'm like, how
do I get, I gotta get more.
So I'd heard everything he said.
I go, okay okay
okay let me recap.
Paid trip, March 9th, Florida.
It was actually in Florida.
$5,000 for a 30 minute talk.
He goes, no, no,
no, no, I said an hour.
I said, oh, I said,
$10,000.
He goes, okay, great.
I'm like, fuck!
(group laughter)
("Li Moe" by Swag Hollywood)